here we go
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast
yo solo episode you know
welcome back
all right ladies and gentlemen we back
in the house you know i've been doing
all these
interviews i don't think anybody likes
them
i don't get i don't know how to do this
podcast i'm almost at 100 episodes
and i still don't have it right so i say
you know what
let me just go to what i feel
comfortable with right now it's just me
just talking about stuff in the world so
here i am
[Music]
this is a completely solo episode rhythm
with griffin
and i hope you enjoy it
but anyways guys yeah you know so you
know after the world went crazy
coronavirus happened and like everything
shut down i i've talked about it
numerous times i was in tennessee
just doing shows at chattanooga and i
was like
you know then after that that's it the
world just went completely bananas
and so then trying to figure out how to
do the podcast i don't necessarily want
people coming to my place
a lot of people don't want to come so
other people are still doing their
podcasts like
i don't got rogan money where i got a
doctor on site doing blood tests and
doing you know and other people that
don't care and then you know and then
you could do another podcast
you know brian and uh [ __ ] job they
they freaking got coronavirus so it's
like
you know what i mean so i don't want to
go places i don't want people coming
here so
i'm doing it like this sort of zoom i
actually record facetime calls
but like i can tell by the viewership
people
just don't like it i don't know what to
say i don't know if you don't like it i
don't know if you don't like me or if
you only like people
if you only like like i feel like people
that watch my podcast and there are some
really
good fans like you got like the people
that come every week you've been here
since the beginning
it's a small group of loyal fans and
then i have a bunch of people that only
want to see
tom segura bobby lee andrew like you
only want to see those guys
because when they're not on you don't
watch my podcast so
the people that are watching right now
obviously you just want to watch me so
here i
am i'm just going to do a solo episode
i'm going to do a bunch of solo episodes
even though i have some
some big guests for like 98 99 100
because you know 100 episodes is a big
deal
but this is how i started it was just me
and my place talking smack on a gopro
so you know here i am once again
i had a really great day really great
sunday today's sunday is probably i'm
gonna put this out the same day
uh every sunday my girlfriend's family
does a zoom call with her grandmother
her grandmother lives in florida she's
by herself
and so they just you know they do like
little videos and stuff and they um
we get on a zoom call and we like share
the videos and it's actually really nice
you know
i can tell she really enjoys it so i
really enjoyed doing that and then like
rachel and i went like
on a drive to malibu like we like going
to this place called paradise cove cafe
right so it's like way up to pch it's a
nice drive it's past pepperdine
so we go and we get to the place
now we've gone before now they got the
best kobe beef ribs
like it's at a good price delicious ribs
so we went when quarantine in the middle
of quarantine
uh you know restaurants weren't really
open yet so they were doing takeout so
we got the kobe beef ribs we actually
went but it was actually a hassle
because we had to call and they were
like we're actually not doing the ribs
but then the lady goes but secretly you
have to ask ask about them and we'll do
it
so we call it first this is back in the
day and then you know they were like
well we don't have them
hey we just talked to the manager
they're like oh okay hold on and then we
picked up the ribs
so now we go and for some reason it's
jam-packed today like i don't know what
the [ __ ] was going on
but pch was jam-packed the beaches were
packed all you know i don't know if
you've ever driven off pch for the
people in la
but you like you drive along and then
like there's like you know all those
little parking spots so
when the quarantine first started it was
a great drive nobody was around now it
was just
jam-packed and we stopped at this place
like there's a fred siegel
there's like this uh the civic center in
malibu i think it's called
and they got all these little outdoor
shops and like little mall
area that [ __ ] was jam-packed and then i
have an electric
car so i usually when i go there's like
five or six electric spots that you can
go and you can park
none of these shits are working you know
and and by the way
side note to [ __ ] about something else
look if you want us to drive electric
cars or you want me to come to your
establishment and you have an electric
car
charging thing make sure the
[ __ ] works okay
because that's why i'm you you made it
like hey come here you can charge your
car
come to my shop if the if the damn
electric [ __ ] ain't working
then i'm like you get stressed out
there's like a phobia about it you know
i don't i i gotta find out what that
phobia is but
you you get all stressed like damn am i
gonna make it home so it's like we go
two of the electric things aren't
working and then there's like a library
right down the street the
malibu library they have free ones there
of course that's full
there's a whole foods in the back and
they got some like uh charge points
those one of them's full and another one
there's like a porsche parked in the
electric parking thing
and that pisses me the [ __ ] off if you
don't have an electric car
don't park in the electric parking just
you know i wanted to key this
motherfucker's car
i was gonna pop his tires i was i was
gonna be a white woman out there like
where's security at
you know i was going karen the [ __ ] up
out there i swear to god
so all right anyways paradise codes they
actually offer free charging too so
but i'm thinking we get it's packed all
the way there driving in
is packed the parking lot is packed you
know they got outdoor seating on the
beach
that's packed you know the lady on the
phone's rude as hell
it's a four hour wait you know i don't
know if there's going to be ribs or not
because we want to get the ribs
so they go all right we get there the
charger is free which is perfect so i
need to charge my car for like an hour
or two just to make sure you know
you know rachel goes in and then she has
to go around the back so i'm parking the
car and i go where are you she's like
i'm in the back
and then and then and then like there's
a security guy out front as being like
a nazi about the masks now listen i'm
all about wearing masks i think it helps
people let's be safe right
but hey watch your tone how you tell me
to put my mask on okay
you all you're doing is inciting
nonsense when you when you acting like a
[ __ ]
well yeah hey hey you need to put your
mask on
you need to hear me hey where's your
mouth you know it's like you know tone
it down a little bit okay tone it down
you know like
just you and you're still in the service
business [ __ ] so act like it you
know what i mean
so anyway i can't stand anywhere you go
where people like
this sort of mask attitude it's like
yeah tone your [ __ ] down
so we have to deal with that then it
turns out you have to go in the back of
the uh
the building so you go in the back and
there's like the beaches right there
and this is the most ghetto ass beach in
malibu because people come from all over
the place and it's just
people with their kids and babies and
like weird ass camping [ __ ] and they're
all out there
on the beach and so you go around the
back of the restaurant and you order
you have to order in the back so there's
a long ass line rachel's got to deal
with some
some lady has an attitude with her
finally get to the front front of the
line
and we go yeah well we just want the
kobe beef ribs on the menu that we've
ordered before we want that to go now
the guy's like well yeah
you know we we have the outdoor because
people can order food out there
and then they take it to go and they sit
at these like cabanas that they have set
up six feet apart
you know but you have to like sign up
for one of those we just want some
[ __ ] ribs to go
can't get them we can't get the menu
ribs like we have to wait four hours to
get a table
then we can get those ribs but we can't
get this from the same [ __ ]
restaurant we can't order the ribs
that we get off the menu and then take
it home no we have to order some
outside ghetto outside beach menu
so we end up getting some fish tacos
would you end up being cold
because we i said let's just eat them in
the car so this was a whole
thing but it was a nice drive it was a
beautiful day and i love spending time
with my girl so
that was today's [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever
what happened to me today but you know
you got to take time you know you got to
take time to like
you know take to find get with your
loved ones and take some time and go
all right but anyways a few things i
wanted to talk about today
just some [ __ ] that's been on my mind
one the first thing is what happened to
disney plus y'all
what happened you know i was talking
about i had like a podcast like
20 episodes ago i was talking about the
streaming wars like which one is
who's in number one what's it looking
like you know
and what the [ __ ] happened to disney
disney
was supposed to have all these marvel
shows that were supposed to come out
all this original content they they
dropped mandalorian on us
and then they haven't done [ __ ] since
what's what's going on
and then you then they made this
announcement that the other shows aren't
even gonna be on the network
and i'm like what like why did i buy
this [ __ ]
why did i get disney plus now i'll say
this
if you subscribe to hulu
okay if you're a hulu person
you should for sure have disney plus
okay you got to get dizzy plus if you
have hulu you should get disney plus
because it's only like a dollar more you
know because
if they bundle it with use espn so it
doesn't necessarily cost you any extra
if you are a hulu person you should get
disney plus
but i got it and i just i'm not a fan
now
like i i feel like it's been all a scam
to me it's a whole big money grub you
know with all these streaming services
look let's just be real about it netflix
is king netflix is winning
excuse me netflix is winning they're
gonna win
they're winning they're blowing all
these things away because they already
have it in place
the only other streaming service
that i think is right on par with them
and probably secretly doing just as well
is
hbo because we've been paying for hbo
way before netflix was even a thing
they've been getting 15 dollars a month
for up from us for for [ __ ] a decade
right so they got their hbo max which is
great
hbo max is great but it's basically hbo
go
they gonna get rid of hbo hbo go i got
fish tacos on my head right now and i'm
all in my throat
sorry so they got rid of hbo go
they're going to phase it out and it's
just going to be hbo max so hbo looked
at what netflix was doing and said oh
this is cool we don't got to be just
movies
so let's get some tv shows which they've
already done and they had game of
thrones they had all these kind of shows
but they're going
you know what let's just actually also
buy some origins from some
let's buy some old content like friends
and those kind of things let's just put
it on hbo max
we'll make some new cartoons we'll make
some new shows and we'll still do what
we've been doing
but that's how we'll come we'll we will
be competition with netflix because
we'll start
being a place where people can bring
their stuff so it's like big bang theory
and your ends and they're like okay
let's put it on hbo you know like so
they're they're stealing things that way
so hbo max secretly to me
is uh is number two to netflix
but apple tv disney these two in
particular
these two greedy [ __ ] that's the only
way i can describe it they're just
greedy
like what is the point like like
apple should have just worked with
netflix they already got the
infrastructure they already got the
thing
work out a deal so we can get the
content that we want it's about the
people
but they made it about the money they
said well if netflix is getting a
subscription service
we should too but they should have seen
that this
ain't easy you can't just throw [ __ ] you
can't throw
three shows on your network and people
be like oh we gotta get that
no it's look with netflix they're
continuously putting out shows
constantly they're spending a billion
dollars in new content
all the time they're taking the money
that we pay them
for the subscription and they're
recycling it fast so they can put out
content at the same time
make a profit margin so these other
things
disney and apple they thought oh we're
gonna do the same thing no [ __ ]
you ain't prepared for it your [ __ ]
sucks
okay it sucks you lost and you know the
people that really lose
we lose we are losing because of it
because now you can't find the [ __ ] that
you want
you got to look all over the place you
got like seven bills on your damn credit
card of all these dumb services that you
have
you have to work out when they should
have just bundled the [ __ ] together
like cable that's what cable did because
we're like you know what instead of
people doing all this [ __ ] let's put it
all together
that's what they should have done but no
now we got to deal with freaking
you know disney it's like look i watched
all the marvel movies i loved it when i
first got disney plus i was like oh this
is dope
i get to watch all the marvel movies you
know iron man i get to watch captain
america
oh this is great but then and then it's
like oh all the disney movies aladdin
you know the quarantine hit and we
watched everything now i'm looking at
this [ __ ] like why am i paying for this
why am i paying for this where's the new
[ __ ] so
i think disney made a mistake i think
they should have worked with netflix
not trying to do this [ __ ] on their own
because they're fake you're failing your
[ __ ]
sucks the product sucks you know it's
just not enough i hate it
and then apple don't even get me started
that's just a disaster
apple tv is a disaster
all right i you know these streaming
services quibby
quibby's another one i'm mad at crippy
because i went in to pitch something and
they didn't buy it so i'm mad at them
so but why would you want that like why
i don't get it i don't get what the
thought process was but that just like
that turned out to be an another
disaster
i read the thing that said like only
five percent of the people
went past the uh free subscription on
quibby
and nobody's watching nobody wants to
watch
you know nobody wants to watch a list
movie stars
just on their phone okay we we
there's a there's a nine-year-old in
milwaukee who i watch on my phone you
know like that's who people watch on
their phone
he's doing a dumb dance with a dog
that's that
[ __ ] that's phone stuff okay i just
dropped my phone see
that's phone [ __ ] you know what i mean
you're not saying like
some 19 year old twins who are like
doing something with a pit bull
that's [ __ ] you watch on your phone all
right people at the beach
falling down that's phone [ __ ] no not
matthew mcconaughey all right i want to
see
no you know what i mean like they got
all these a-list stars thinking that we
want to know i don't want to look at
alien stars like this [ __ ] i want to
look at a-list stars
on the movie screen on my tv okay
because then it's like because that's
because we know that we need high
production value because you're bringing
high production you bring in
you know you're raising the quality of
performance and acting
because you put money into that so show
it to us on
you know what i mean you don't go to
ruth chris
and you know and eat at a picnic table
you know that's that's
who wants that you want the ambiance of
the a-list celebrity
you know i go eat you when you go spend
70 on a porterhouse steak at some
fancy-ass restaurant
or wherever y'all go some of y'all go to
sizzler either way you
want the whole thing
to look nice that's the whole point of
it so
i get mistake with the candle the three
waiters that come over
the music playing you know the nice
tablecloth
that's how you want to eat a good ass
steak not
where the [ __ ] not on a picnic table at
a park because
that's what quibby is you know quibby's
like here's some filet mignon but you
gotta look at the [ __ ]
on a on a [ __ ] coaster like what what
i don't know anyways money grabs you
know what i mean that's all it is
it's all money grabs so netflix is king
these people should have worked out
deals with netflix i think apple
just all the all the the movie studios
who have their own thing
[ __ ] don't work one that i think that
does
sort of work but it's so specific as a
niche market
is dc universe didn't talk about dc
universe last time i
did the thing and i should have i
actually love dc universe
and by the way dc universe has a they
actually have a deal with hbo because
like
all the shows that are on dc universe
they actually end up on
hbo max or the the major ones but dc
universe you can look at comic books you
can see all the dc cartoons all the dc
movies
and they have original content like
harley quinn
there's three great shows on dc universe
harley quinn
titans and uh doom squad
all great and what i love about them is
adult content they're all for
adults it's adult there's cursing
there's violence there's blood
i love that type of [ __ ] it's like i
call it rated r robin that's what titans
is it's like robin is
gritty and you know i love it okay don't
like the guy that played batman i don't
really think that that guy could be
batman but that's not even
that doesn't matter it's still great so
and they i'm sure they're coming out
with other new stuff about all these
cartoons and stuff and then it goes over
to hbo max like harley quinn is great
great cartoon my buddy ron funches plays
like a killer shark
in it um that's just dope
you know harley quinn is just a funny
raunchy
cartoon harley quinn raunchy so i do
suggest you
uh if you if you want to say well do i
want to spend like seven dollars a month
on something else
or you could just get hbo if you already
have hbo you you have hbo max
just wait and like the show's cause
harley quinn just came to hbo max right
now
so i think that that one's doing good
but like i say i just think these other
ones
you know hulu i think is also a winner
just because
you know you can see all the like the
network shows a lot of network shows and
they have a lot of original movies and
original content
so i still think it goes right now i'm
ranking that netflix is king
no one is even close then i would say
hbo max right now i think is second
then hulu bundled with disney and espn
and then amazon now amazon has some
great shows
amazon does have but amazon don't give a
[ __ ] they make it so much money
they're just like they got refrigerator
money so they don't care about
content you know they just go okay let's
just put some content out just to
compete
but they're not it's not it's not their
focus but they do have some great
content on there but that's just it's
not enough to say beat netflix i mean
netflix got so many great movies and
shows
you know it's like even they'll put out
so they have a lot of shitty shows too
right but they put out so much content
that
they don't have to worry about if the
two big shows they put out tank
because they got a hundred shows and
maybe 20 of them are good you know and
that's really that's great odds and uh
when you talk about tv because at tv it
does so bad every year
in terms of like you know shows that
come on and they just get canceled
but i think that uh netflix is still
king nobody's beating
gonna beat netflix and they and and i i
feel like these things are gonna cave
and they're just gonna be like hey let's
work out a deal you know but
like i said i think it's
um netflix hbo max and then
like a subsidiary of that being dc
universe but that's such a niche market
that i don't i don't really count it in
the rankings
because like i say you can look at these
you can look at comic books on there
i mean it's a really like if you're in
the comic books if you're a nerd like
that i really do suggest you check out
dc universe go get the free
subscription and check that out
yeah but i really was talking [ __ ] about
this because
i just feel like disney plus is a damn
scam like where are you disney plus
what are you doing put out your [ __ ]
shows man
what's going on i want to see
mandalorian season two we had a damn
pandemic do
at home doing nothing a lot of us or
some of us are just you know struggling
to pay bills
depressed like put out content you know
put out this [ __ ] that makes it so
they'll be like oh okay
you know i can distract myself for a
little bit from all this freaking
craziness
all right that's my rant about the
netflix
now here's what i'm talking about now
i you guys know if you've been watching
my podcast for this whole time
and if you're new to me right now i love
90 day fiance i love all the shows like
they have 90 day fiance
all these different ones but i just
started watching this new one called 90
day fiance
the other way this [ __ ] is bananas
bananas now nowadays fiance
is basically somebody from america the
original was
somebody from a foreign country usually
somebody who wants to move to the united
states
they're probably attractive sometimes
you know most of the time they got
something you know and they find some
lonely ass american
all right this is 80 of the time it's
some lonely person who's
like it's unfortunately older
fat you know just like you know out of
shape or there's something weird about
them
and then you know they got some kind of
quirk
and then they have 90 days to get
married and so that person can get a
green card
it's really transparent when you watch
the show you're just like
what the [ __ ] are you doing that person
don't love you they just want your money
now there's a small percentage like like
i say
20 25 30 of the people it's a couple
that you go well they look like a good
looking couple they
but they even got problems because
they'll be like the families get
together and they're crazy
or one of them's just a complete nut bag
and it causes all this friction right
but for the most part it's a couple two
two people you go that chick don't love
you dude
she's just trying to get a green card i
mean that's you're watching this and
then
the drama of the show is all the
[ __ ] that the person goes through
with this person now you know 90 day
fiance to me is just
it's like it's like emotional catfishing
you know
like catfish is another show i love to
watch before but at this point how you
still getting catfished right
but catfish is like that's all about
it's so superficial because it's all
about looks
you know it's all about somebody lying
about who they really are
appearance wise now everything after
that
go that's everything after that because
if you're lying about how you look
you're probably lying about your job
you're lying about your career
you're lying about where you live you're
lying about you know if you're a woman
and you're pretending to be a man i mean
you know everything you say after that
is nullified because you're not the
person that you said you are
even physically so we obsess about that
when we watch catfish because we're like
that person is not who they saying they
are but all the little details
that's the [ __ ] that happens in 90 day
fiance the the all those details
the details of lies you know it's
emotional catfishing you know
because even with catfish like why does
catfish work like what happens to people
like
a lot of us sit at home we watch these
kinds of things and we go oh that'll
never happen to me
you know but we don't you don't realize
because before the internet people were
getting conned
all the time people get conned you know
people lie about who they are what they
are like
and even before the internet there was
no way to really even
fact check or you can't catch anybody
but imagine how people were getting
conned before before
when people can just have a fake license
or i mean i just i'm just saying this
you know i know you're sitting at home
and you're going like well that would
never happen to me but
you would be surprised so what what is
it what is the psychological
trauma that's going on with people like
why do people
have this need to to feel loved
or is that what it is like or or is it
like
i want to save someone like it's some
kind of
weird thing when you're somebody and you
go here's someone some
someplace else and they're always in a
terrible situation
and you what does this need to feel like
well i'm gonna fix that person's life
and i'm falling in love with them i just
i
i'm trying to understand it because i
get it i've been catfished in the past
because i was i'm old school i like when
it first started you know i was around
when the internet just
you know i'm from the golden age of the
internet you know yahoo chat you know
and all that kind of [ __ ]
but i got rid of all that because it was
just like perversion everywhere right
so it was easy easier to get catfished
back then
so you know it's happened to me but like
you know you wonder like what is the
mentality of somebody
that does that kind of stuff so catfish
we kind of understand it's really
transparent you know we look at it and
we go the person is lying about who they
are and we know why
the person's either like you know they
feel like they're ugly or they
actually are ugly or whatever they're
using a model's picture so
they that's their standard of beauty
they think that i should look like this
and they don't look like that and so
what happens is we you know we look at
it and go oh that's [ __ ] up
now 90 day fiance is a whole other thing
though
it's like that girl nicole i talked
about her before you know just
she's a cute fat chick she cute you know
cute face but she's giving all her money
to this skinny moroccan dude
moving her kids the kid part i just
don't understand
i just don't get it she's going to take
her kid
to morocco what
what [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] you doing
like like
you getting kept you getting you getting
catfished
emotionally catfished and you bringing
your kid into it i just don't get it
now they got this new one this new
version
now that they financially the other way
now this is even worse to me
because what it is now is here's the
american
and instead of them marrying somebody so
they can get their green card
and live in the united states these dumb
[ __ ]
are gonna go live in these batshit crazy
places
with the person they met on the internet
i just want to go through the couples so
you can
get a gist all right first couple
jenny and summit jenny's 60
okay she a 60 year old grandma
got barely any money in the bank got a
lot of k
she got grandkids her daughter three or
three daughters
everybody loves her she happy she in a
relationship with this [ __ ] from
india he's
30. she's 60 he's 30. they barely know
each other i don't know how long they've
been see i don't know if this is season
two or whatever
but i love the i love not knowing the
backstory
because i like looking at this and being
like how the [ __ ] did these two people
get to this point
but she she only got like four thousand
dollars in the bank
and she gonna move to india and he lined
his ass up he talking about i live
i think i i think this [ __ ] is
married i think
i haven't seen all the season yet so i'm
i'm knee deep in it so you probably
already know
and i'm i'm telling you now so wait till
i talk about it again once i find out
all the things
but he talked about he living with his
parents
and he can't be with her because they'll
disown him
because she came and they met and you
know it looks quite crazy
she's 60 like this age
whatever it's just a number i get it but
there's there's other factors that go
into
you up rooting your life leaving your
grandchildren you're leaving
your family because because of some dude
you're gonna move to india you move into
india [ __ ]
i i just i don't get it people say
they're in love
but what it's always poor people if
i feel like people with no options that
that think
love is the end-all like there's no
common sense
nothing you just gonna uproot your life
take your four thousand dollar savings
and go to india with a with a thirty
year old
who they crazy that whole relationship
so i'm knee deep in it right now where
he left her at home because his parents
wanted him to come back because he
by the way he lived with his parents he
30 live with his parents now i know
that's how they do it in that part of
the world
but when you're coming from your part of
the world these
these cultures collide you know so what
the [ __ ]
anyway jenny gonna find out the truth
i think he's married i think it's not
his parents he lived with
now and imagine how [ __ ] up that is
that but what i'm saying is that's how
easy it is to emotionally catfish
someone
because you don't like when you're doing
a long-distance relationship
when you're doing an over-the-internet
relationship only thing that's real
is the moments when you're talking with
each other there's no consequences
there's no
outside forces you're only dealing with
this and you can say
and be and do whatever you want once you
get together
life gets in the way because you got to
pay bills you got to actually get along
with each other you got to deal with
each other's quirks and idiosyncrasies
and that's that's real life and that's
harder
you know that's why people want to live
on the internet because it's just a
[ __ ] lie
so that's jenny and summit summit sami i
don't know what it is so i bet you
i bet you he had to leave because his
wife was like where the [ __ ] are you you
know what i mean
all right then you got
ji hoon and devin this one's crazy
okay he asian fine i'm not nothing
against that
he lives in south korea with his parents
in a shitty ass apartment it's a little
as [ __ ] okay he lives in south korea
with his parents
he meet this girl devin she's fine she's
cute you know what i mean she's fine
her pictures make her you know she got
to work on her makeup this i just think
that that dark i don't
i'm not a fan of like dark hair dark
makeup
features you look you know and then she
got this little girl named
driscilla monster the kid is a monster
but driscilla like i don't get that name
i don't know why you would name your kid
drusilla but she probably got her
reasons more power to her
so they talking on the internet for like
i don't know how long
you know they finally meet up
and he gets her pregnant like
what she 23 she only 23
with like a six year old so she should
know better herself
but he's so enamored by this american
beauty he come
bust right in her and she pregnant so
now no matter what
they wrapped up in each other's lives
for the rest of their lives
so she talking about moving to south
korea
she gonna take a little monster kid and
move to south korea
what i don't get it you know and then
the parents had to come and accept her
so their relationship is just weird i i
you know i and i can tell that reality
is going to get in the way of that
relationship because why would you want
to leave
she live in a nice house with her family
he came
and he's looking around the house and
he's like damn this house is nice
j hoon was like [ __ ] my house sucks
compared to this
so he's like i don't know how she's
gonna deal with it so i can't wait to
see what happens with that
all right then there's paul and karina
and they in a little [ __ ] fish town in
brazil okay
paul is a man baby this [ __ ] was
living with his mother
got barely any money he goes over there
gets
her pregnant she come he she get
pregnant and she has a miscarriage
and then she mysteriously gets pregnant
again and he's like
the only smart thing he's saying is i
need to get this baby tested we need to
do a dna test
yeah [ __ ] you need to do a dna
test because she got pregnant too fast
but like he don't got no money he don't
got no money
he got nothing and he goes to live
in some backwater town mo [ __ ]
you know just pigs and [ __ ] in the
street
he go and then she is so worried
that she wants so they live in a place
where the medical the medical facilities
aren't necessarily like they are in the
united states so it's already scary
she already had a miscarriage but she's
scared to be by herself
so she want to move to some even more
backwater town where they got to go on a
five-day weird-ass yacht boat
to go to her village to so she could be
with her mom and he trying to find work
right but then come to find out that he
has a record he got
legal problems where he can't even get
work or a visa they calling him a
terrorist and
the way he like he's such a baby just
the way he reacts to things
he just like flies off the handle and
they can't speak english they can't
speak the language to each other so
they're using the google translator
the [ __ ] is bananas they're always
fighting and then this
she on her phone talking with other
dudes
getting money from other american men so
i'm like yo paul why did you move
i just don't get the the process of
uplifting your life
and moving to not like you move into
a first world country you move into some
backwater third world country and then
in that third world country you go into
the third world part of the third world
country i
i just don't get it that couple like
they
they bananas okay and so
and she's [ __ ] about to burst you
know and and how do you go
and then he is so stubborn like he you
know he don't got no money
he got his little savings which i don't
know how much the [ __ ] that is and he
don't want to spend money like
so they go look at some houses right and
the houses like one of them's like
a thousand american a month it ain't
even nice
by the way but it had
air conditioning and in that [ __ ]
place it's okay
so the girl's like we can't afford this
you ain't even working
are you supposed to take care of me that
kind of attitude by the way but anyways
that's a whole other thing
so then they go look at another one this
one's like 250
a month i looked at rachel and i was
like yo we we could go live there
we could we could live like we could
have a palace in that little village
but anyway he don't want to live there
he's like i like the other one better
[ __ ] you don't got a job paul you can't
even work
you on the [ __ ] terrorist list you
might get deported
and you talk about you want the little
[ __ ] hut with the air conditioning over
the other one that you can afford
they crazy so i can't see wait to see
what happens with them
all right what's some other ones ronald
and tiffany
this is the one i don't understand now
ronald
love his family they in south africa
dangerous ass south africa love his
family his mom is the
sweet lady his family is sweet but
ronald
is a is a gambler so he has a problem he
gambled away all his money
he he has an addiction he has a gambling
addiction
so he went into [ __ ] rehab because of
it and they were together
i don't know how so tiffany is this cute
heavyset lady
chick and she got like a little
eight-year-old son
so they have this like online romance
he's in south africa and you know they
keep talking about what he put me
through because she didn't know about
his gambling addiction and all this [ __ ]
and i'm like that should have been
enough it's a wrap
for the simple fact that she's not by
herself
she has her eight-year-old son and she
got the eight-year-old son
calling him dad what
what so this okay
so this [ __ ] so tiffany that's
her name tiffany and ronald
tiffany she gets her son
right don't tell her family nobody
nothing about how
yeah ronald can't come to the united
states because he got a criminal record
that's because he's a criminal by the
way and there's more [ __ ] on his record
due to his gambling addiction that he
got into some criminal activity
and she's still like i'm gonna move me
and my son
are gonna go to south africa i wha what
for love are you kidding me so then they
get there
you know she get there and he's
revealing you know he's revealing his
[ __ ] this is all that i've done
he don't got a job he don't got no money
the sister comes and you know tiffany's
like
you can call him brother and the
sister's like um i
first of all can i talk about this i
can't stand that [ __ ]
just because if when your family member
gets into if you have a brother
and your brother starts dating a chick
and they serious but you don't really
know her that well and you don't know
what's going on
don't [ __ ] tell me oh this is your
sister now it ain't my sister
[ __ ] i don't know this [ __ ] i
don't know her
okay so let me get to know her let us
build a relationship and then i'll tell
you when i would be like okay
she she's like family to me now but i
ain't gonna be on
your timeline okay so i totally with the
sister she was like yeah
y'all ain't married yet so he ronald to
me and i was like you damn right
don't make any sense i just don't
understand why
you would put and then she keeps talking
about south africa ain't safe because
the [ __ ] ain't safe
they get married which is bananas to me
but they get married her mother can't
even come you know they get married
then they go look at apartments he don't
got a job they go to the realtor and the
realtors like well how much money do you
make
and they go well you can't afford the
good place because in south africa
you have to live in a gated community
with [ __ ] security you got to have
electric fences and it's it's crazy
and tiffany's like well i can't have my
eight-year-old son he can't be running
in the streets
because they they'll snatch him up he'll
be human trafficked all over the damn
place
like south africa the way they describe
it in the show
it ain't good so they go to this
[ __ ] apartment building
and sh you know the lady's like yeah you
know this is
uh the the security there's the fences
with the electric electricity and
listen if somebody come this is what the
realtor said to her if somebody comes
you know somebody trying to get in you
gotta
there's a lot of people around so you
just gotta scream somebody will come
what [ __ ] what
what bye i'm out
okay i'm out you you lost me on
electric fence i'm out okay i'm taking
my eight-year-old son
and we out but now she in the position
where
she gotta move to south africa because
this [ __ ] can't get a job and he
got a criminal record he ain't gonna be
able to get a visa
because he got a criminal record it's
like
all that [ __ ] to me is more important
than love all that stuff is like
you know what and i've been in love i'm
in love right now okay
so i'm saying this before you go down
the road of getting in
being in love with someone you need to
find out
what the [ __ ] looks like
internet people what they look like
what do they do what's the truth behind
everything is it practical
this is the stuff you need to find out
before you then you don't come later and
be like well i'm in love so i'm gonna do
it it's like [ __ ] what like you can't
no so tiffany and ronald i don't know
what's gonna happen with that situation
but the [ __ ] is crazy
two more couples then we're gonna go
this
this couple i can't stand evelyn and
corey
i hate evelyn okay like
i get in trouble because people like
don't call women [ __ ] listen i call
everyone a [ __ ] because i don't mean
[ __ ] the way you think i mean [ __ ]
when i say [ __ ] i mean [ __ ]
i just like saying [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] that's how i say i call
everybody [ __ ]
evelyn she a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
a [ __ ] [ __ ] like this dude i don't
know how long they've been together
corey he he live in he's a mormon
he you know so he already batshit okay
so he
he living in minnesota or washington
wherever he lives with his mormon family
he gonna give i don't see this might be
season two because
um i don't know how this even got to
this point but
he had forty thousand dollars to save
his life savings he gave it all to her
to open
a bar okay on the beach in her little
[ __ ] town
and you know fix her their apartment and
all this [ __ ] because he loves her
this [ __ ] packs up his life
first of all she comes
meets the family trashes mormons okay
right in front of the family at the same
time saying like
i don't know if i really want a family
she's saying this guy corey is mormon he
wants 75 children
he wants to have a bunch of kids and be
a family man he's a good looking guy
you know he's he's got a he's got a
sweet demeanor he feels he feels like a
good guy
he's he just wants to be in love and
this [ __ ] is like
nah i don't know if i want that that's
not my dream that's not my wish
she says it to his ass over and over and
over again right
he still pack up all his [ __ ] and moves
to this [ __ ]
listen there's third world countries
and then there's the third world area of
the third world country that's where
this [ __ ] lives
okay this is the part that pissed me off
this [ __ ] gets on a plane to go
to ecuador
he gotta take three planes to get where
she is when he gets to the airport
the [ __ ] ain't there okay she ain't at
the airport to pick him up
he done uprooted his life and she ain't
at the airport
right he calls her this [ __ ]
says
well sorry but you can take the bus
you're a big boy
[Music]
what what [ __ ]
what i'm i'm a big boy
i would just on general on gp
okay general principal i would take the
bus
just to spit in her face [ __ ] you come
to the airport and pick me up when i'm
changing my life and you got 40 000
of my dollars in the bank for some
[ __ ] ass bar you don't [ __ ] leave
me at the airport you come get me
she's a monster i'm just telling you
right now and he's a diva
like because like when you're
even the shittiest apartment in l.a
what you would consider shitty the
things you have in there
you don't even think about not having
running water hot water
air conditioning or a fan electrical
outlets
you know stoves unrusty pots
no bugs those kind of things that like
you just take for granted
in ecuador that's like that's just how
they [ __ ] live
and then she cheated on his ass with
another white dude
he walking around this little fish town
and [ __ ] are calling him the
name of the other white dude she was
with
and he mad about it he come to her like
yo they don't know me
and she's like and then she goes well
the other guy was you know she basically
is like the other guy was better than
you you know
like just how she her context i can't
stand that couple i think it's
ridiculous
i i just think it's ridiculous like she
had no desire to move to united states
by the way i agree with her i don't
he live on some [ __ ] farm with his
mormon family
there's nothing around she's like [ __ ]
that i'd rather be with my family and
friends where she's like queen bee
you know what i mean she's like an
ecuador eight you know she
you know you you gotta go over there and
be in ecuador
be the queen be that place so i totally
get why she didn't want to move there
but this couple i i can't stand them
last couple
to me most infuriating couple laura
and aladdin i don't know i think his
name is aladdin but it's spelled aladdin
so [ __ ] it he gonna be aladdin
she 51 okay let's open with
laura 51. aladdin 29
just chiseled in shape dude laura 51
like she got like old school pageant
hair
she just you know what i mean she's 51
let's just you know i mean she let
herself go
and she's just living her life she's a
she's a strong ass woman you know what i
mean she's just like
[ __ ] it this is me this is who i am deal
with it
i respect that about her i don't get
why they together okay not just because
of her but even on her side like why
would you want to be with some 29 year
old
arab guy who lives in qatar like not
that there's anything wrong with eric
i'm talking about
he actually lives in qatar and lives by
that their lifestyle where you can have
four wives and women aren't treated
like you think women are treated great
in that part of the world
there ain't no me too movement in
[ __ ] you know
qatar okay all right
so they're knee-deep in their
relationship and so
i'm picking up on this point they're
already married okay so they got married
right she talking [ __ ] about the guy
she's super jealous which i can't stand
i hate
jealousy is so it's just it's such a
it really is terrible on a relationship
if you were just
you can't get your jealousy in in in
intact you can't
[ __ ] you need to work on that if
you're a person that's super jealous you
got to work on that because it is just
detrimental to your relationship
so she's super jealous you know she's
always on his instagram and [ __ ] like
who's this girl who's that
like who do you think it is lady like
are you kidding me
so he gotta block her for four days at a
time
until she cools down but she's gonna
move
she has her son is just the sweetest kid
they're actually they're really i love
their relationship it makes me like tear
up think because i like i'm a mama's boy
i was an only child and i live you know
it's me and my mom so when i see their
relationship i
get it they are so close and she's gonna
leave him to go move to
qatar with this [ __ ]
who i don't know what he does i don't
know if he has money
so here's the thing okay now here's a
here's the thing they say they love each
other whatever the love i don't get the
love all right
she's going now you might say well look
she's a 15 year old one-year-old woman
here's this young handsome in-shape dude
i you know that's what
men do the same thing men are with hot
younger women i'm with a hot younger
woman right so i get it you get that
thing right but like for laura
all she does is trash the dude like
she's always talking about how
he sucks in bed well if he sucks in bed
why are you going like what what because
that seems to be the thing you go well
that's what's keeping them together
right some kind of weird sexual
attraction because he's obviously into
older women
so it's something like and if that's not
going well what's the [ __ ] point
so she she gets on a plane goes to
guitar
she brings a vibrator because she
she's she just this she knows
she's 51 so she know how her junk works
okay she knows what she needs she knows
how she needs to get it done
she knows what she needs him to do he
sho she shows him the vibrator and this
[ __ ] flips out
he's like [ __ ] you you know what i i
don't
you know he's like i should be enough
and that just made me laugh
this is what we're gonna end on right
now like i don't think that couple's
gonna work that [ __ ] is crazy
but guys don't be afraid
of the sex toys that your girl needs
i know some of y'all think you king you
got king dick
i know you think your dick is the best
dick ever
and you think you rocking her world and
she you
and you some of y'all are you rocking
her world
but let me just tell you something you
ain't better
than that electronic [ __ ]
face it get your girl to come into the
room right now i wait
go on tell your girl to come in i want
her to watch this while i'm telling you
this
your dick ain't better than that
vibrator
straight up that that sucker
embrace it bring it into the bedroom
it encourage her do you girl
get get it done cause that sucker just
like just you there's nothing you can do
this is bionic man [ __ ]
okay there's nothing your fleshy ass
dick
can do that this thing
don't let your ego get in the way
of your woman's pleasure bring that [ __ ]
in
embrace the idea even when
you tear that [ __ ] up and you know you
gave it to her she still
wants to use that vibrator okay
i'm just telling you right now and i
don't want to hear all i know all the
jokes that are
in the comments right now oh that's you
well maybe you did
no no [ __ ] i throw down i know
what i got going on
okay i'm a i'm a pleaser all right i go
down
i got i do tongue aerobics okay don't
even think
don't don't fool yourself daddy take
care of business
but i know that those devices
my girl got this one that's like
[ __ ] you you could
use this [ __ ] on a construction site
okay i'm just telling you
when you feel the power and you're like
you're like oh there's nothing i there's
nothing i could do
to to there's nothing i could do that
that's the same as this
you have to understand that we bring
other things the intimacy the hugging
the kissing the holding the that
that that connection like good the
really great sex has to do with
your mind your best sex organ is your
brain you know and that connection is
what
they desire and love and need i would
assume you know they
i'm not speaking for women because you
know all the me too [ __ ] is about to you
know go down in the comments i'm just
saying
in my experience it feels like that is
the important part the connection the
feeling
you know but when it just comes down to
just raw pleasure
when it comes down to like i just i need
you to feel man
you ain't better than that [ __ ]
machine man
you like mapquest okay so you like a
piece of paper
the directions are on there it tells you
where to go it's easy to follow easy to
figure out
but dad vibe that vibrator that [ __ ]
gps
turn right here you know you are two
meters away
i mean that is just a the same thing
but different on another
level anyways
i do recommend watching 90 day fiance if
you like to hate watch [ __ ]
i love hate watching stuff like that
show infuriates me
i love watching it i love sitting in
there and i just like i love
i just watch it like this who why the
[ __ ] would you do that who is that why
would you do that that's me when i watch
it i just love that it brings out those
kind of emotions in me
so i do suggest you watch it but the
[ __ ] is
listen to me bananas okay the show's
bananas
but anyways guys i i appreciate you guys
watching
i'm just gonna start doing way more solo
episodes shorter interviews
the jury has spoken you know i guess i'm
just i'm just looking to see
i don't even know if people are even
gonna like this but it is what it is
this is how i'm gonna do it i do have
some special big episodes coming up so
please watch those and listen
if you like watching gaming videos if
you're a person who likes
to watch games or just you want to watch
me game i
game every day on twitch eric griffin
gaming
so make sure you follow that too i love
doing that
and i'll continue to bring you with him
with griffin but
listen uh stay safe out there
uh you know i wish you all the best um
you know take care of your loved ones
wear a mask stay away from your elder
elder people in your life you know even
if you're a conspiracy theorist even if
you don't believe this [ __ ] hey
what does it hurt just to make sure just
to be safe
i hear there's a lot of great stuff
going on with the vaccines
uh you know i do suggest you go to this
website called the milken institute made
by michael
milton he was the junk bond guy from the
80s he went to jail and now he's a
philanthropist and he's got a great
website
that tracks a lot of the vaccines and
there's like there's over there's
hundreds of vaccines in clinical trials
right now so
i do feel like the scientists are going
to like get their [ __ ] together and
figure this out so i'm rooting for that
but anyways that's been another episode
of rifle with griffin
solo and i hope you enjoyed and uh
i'll see you guys
[Music]
you